[Musique]
des chaussons alors ça c'est soit une
paire de talons très précieux et donc
enveloppé dans le rouge pour pas qu'ils
s'abîment surtout avec les conditions
atmosphériques actuelle les talons c'est
fragile donc on l'aimait pas d'abord
c'est dangereux et on les met pas dans
la neige
donc c'est évidemment une paire de
talons j'ai pas les couilles jamais je
vois un poumon carbonisés je veux
également un chausson aux pommes tiède
et mis en contraste sûr vous me dites
non mais moi j'ai aucune preuve que
c'est vrai ce que vous me dites donc
puisque vous continuer à persévérer dans
l'erreur c'est un coeur mais c'est un
coeur particulier c'est le coeur d'un
chamois des andes
c'est à dire que ils ont au dessus des
ventricules des petits poils qui leur
permettent d'affronter le froid bonne
réponse commence à m'emmerder celui-là à
l'artiste contemporain scie sauteuse
alors des tacos walid et à cause
normal non
ah j'aurais jamais pu nom est en cause
c'est pas moi dans mon univers à des
tacos tacos là du coup je vois
[Musique]